[موسيقى]
نرحب بمشاهدي فرانس 24
على فيسبوك او على صفحه البرنامج على
التويتر مثل ما لا تشاهدون على الشاشه لان
لم نراعي سنبدا معكم النقاش بمتابعه خلاص
شوفوا
لمتابعتي روبورتاج خاص من الجبهه في شرق
اوكرانيا للزمالك
الفرنسيه تقرير تحت عنوان الصراع من اجل
البقاء في محمود
ديسمبر 2022
ندخل مدينه بخموت اعنف وانشط الجبهات في
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الى جزئين
القوات الاوكرانيه تتمثل في الجزء الغربي
اما القوه الروسيه فنجحت في الدخول الى
الضواحي شرقا حيث المواجهات بالاسلحه
الخفيفه القصف المدفعي لا يتوقف ليل نهار
[موسيقى]
فيسبوك
المعلومات سريه
تطلق النار قليلا
عائلته
اوكرانيا
هذا المبنى يستخدم لاجلاء الجنود المصابين
في الصفوف الاولى
200 300 متر على ابعد التقدير
بعد اشهر من القتال لم تعد مشاهد الحرب
تشغل المدنيين
ولا يخافون الوضع عادي بالنسبه اليهم
الشوارع خاليه في مدينه سكنها 70000 شخصا
قبل الحرب تحولت كلها الى الساحه معركه
لا اتصالات ولا ماء وكهرباء ولا غاز انا
ونيكولاي واطفالهم الثلاثه يسرعون نحو
مركزا للمساعده الانسانيه
لشحن الهواتف والاتصال بالانترنت
والاستراحه دافئه واحاديث مع اخرين
ربنا
لم تصيب شقتنا بل دمرت شقه جيراننا اطفات
انا وزوجي نيران وحدنا مدرستي تهدمت اتعلم
في المدرسه رقم خمسه
بامكاني ان اجري الاتصال فورا البيت جميل
حقا وسيكون مثاليا للاولاد
من سيحتاجوا الى المساعده
يمكن نيره
لم ينجح في اقناع العائله بالمغادره
الروسيه فقط
لهم اشياء كثيره
بقي في بخموت اقل من عشره في المئه من
سكانها لكن القدره على الاحتمال تستنفذ
بينهم هذه حالو انجلينا
النار
تستحبنا انجلينا الى حيث كانت تسكن قبل
ثلاثه ايام اصابت ضربه للمبنى
[موسيقى]
كان فيها سرير كبير كبير
بعدها قررت انجلينا مع صديقها مكسيم
مغادره محمود
قبل ذلك بسته اسابيع كانت قد اضطرت الى
تركي منزل العائله
[موسيقى]
وقتل معظم من كان في الاغبياء افراد عائله
انجلينا كانوا في الخارج فنجوا
[موسيقى]
هنا
مش هتقعد مع عائلتي تركت المدينه
[موسيقى]
نتجنب هذا النقاش في العائله
بين تاييد لاوكرانيا او لروسيا
انجلينا اكدت لنا ان وليد
الروسيه الارثوذكسيه لمحاولته
وصابر يا وسخ
[موسيقى]
ويصدقائك
صدقه
القداس يقام في السرداب على ضوء الشموع
الكسندر والد انجلينا هنا بالفعل اتى
ليصلي مع ولديه
[موسيقى]
يقبل الكسندر باستقبالنا
بيته في قلب المواجهات
القديمه
الكسندر وولد عبد العوده للعيش تحت القصف
في البدايه كنا عاجزين عن النوم كان الامر
مخيفا راح البيت يرتد والارضيه كانت تهتز
كالهلام حرفيا
كالهلامدر توجهت مع حفيدها الى روسيا
انجلينا تريد التوجه
الاب مع ابنه هنا
وكريمه
اوكرانيا اضافه الى روسيا وبيلاروسيا ليست
سوى بلد واحدا وشعب واحد هي ورده واحده
باصان مختلفه
اعتقد انها لا تريد رؤيتنا لم يجبرها احد
على المغادره تركتنا بملء ارادتها ولم
يطردها احد هي لا تحب طريقه عيشنا تريد
الحريه
الحريه بمفهمها السيد
الاوكرانيات تتحسن في شوارع المدينه
وساحاتها الجنود يتوارون في خنادق تجهز
تحسبا لاي تقدم روسي
تستعر المعارك شرق المدينه
الجنود الاوكرانيون يقولون انهم استعدوا
مربعات سكنيه هجمها الجنود الروس مدعومين
بمرتزقه من المجموعه
او ان دماغهم مغسول تماما لا يستسلمون
ابدا ولا يمكن ايقافهم هذا مروع
الوضع معقد نبعدهم لكنهم يعودون للتسلل
مره بعد مره بعد مره مثل الصراصير هناك
خسائر كثيره في صفوفنا هناك جرح كثير
لكن سيارات الاسعاف تنقل المصابين على
مدار الساعه يوزعون على مستشفيات العسكريه
كهذه
[تصفيق]
ترجمه ترجمه
[موسيقى]
لقد تم استهدفهنا
قذيفه مزقت رجلي
هذا ما حدث هذا استطيع ان اقول رجلي
تؤلمني لكن على ذلك كل شيء بخير
اللهم اجعلك مات ههه
كل شيء كان هادئا وفجاه بدا القذف
عندما اشتد كثيرا اختباء الجميع
صباح اليوم التالي حان وقت الرحيل بالنسبه
الى انجلينا ومكسيم
ينقلان حقائبهما من قبل لاحد الاصدقاء
من
التواصل معنا
[موسيقى]
امس بكيت كثيرا الامر صعب حقا لا رغبه لي
في الرحيل
الى مدينه نيبر على بعد 260 كيلو مترا
غربا هناك ستبدا
حياه جديده
على الطريق
ومعي في الاستديو يا زميلها ميس عواد معنا
من القاهره محمد الشهاوي وهو مستشار في
كليه القاده والاركان
المصريه ومعنا من جنيف حسنه بيدي استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه اهلا وسهلا بكم مبدا معك
ميساء حرب استنزاف بيتم معنى كلمه
على الخسائر الحقيقيه لكن ما لا يمكن
انكاره هو هذه الخسائر الكبيره كما راينا
في التقرير احدى اهم النقاط التي حاولنا
الحصول عليها وبالمناسبه الدخول الى
المستشفى العسكري الذي رايناه في هذا
الوثائقي لم يكن امرا سهل رسميا هذا ممنوع
لكن استطعنا ان ندخل
وفور وصولنا بالفعل كان الجميع متعاونا
لهذا استطعنا الحصول على شهادات الجنود
همم الاكيد انا اتحدث هنا نحن كنا في
الجانب الاوكراني من المدينه لكن لي همم
ابدا همم بعيدا عن الدقه ان قلنا انه في
المقلب الاخر في الجانب الروسي الخسائر
هائله ايضا ولو انها لا تظهر الى الاعلام
الكثيره طيب اريد ان اسالك ضيف من القاهره
محمد الشهاوي في حرب استنزاف مثل هذه الان
هناك تعنت من الطرفين وتابعت بالتاكيد هذا
الريبورتاج لميسي عواد نرى ان المساله هي
مساله بقى بالنسبه الاوكرانيين وايضا
بالنسبه للروس ولكن كل طرف له اهداف
وانا بعتقد ان خلال الفتره القادمه بنجد
انه لابد ان يلجا الطرفين الى سيناريوهات
متعدده اول ان تتصاعد العمليات العسكريه
كل الطرف يريد ان يحذر ان يحرم انتصارا
واعتقد ان الوضع العسكري على الارض سيطول
وزي ما بيقول رجل المخابرات الامريكي
مايلز كوبلاند بيقول ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تريد ان ان يطول امد الحرب
وبالتالي بنجد ان هناك امداد بالاسلحه
والمعدات العسكريه وخاصه الان اصبحت معدات
عسكريه متطوره مثل منظومه الدفاع الجوي
باترون بالرغم انها سلاح دفاعي والا انها
ستقلل الخسائر وخاصه ضد البنيه الاساسيه
السيناريو الثاني هو ان يلجا الطرفين الى
العقلانيه والى العقل والى المنطق لانه لن
يكون هناك منتصر انتصارا ساحقا من قبل
الطرفين وبالتالي بنجد ان روسيا الان
والقوات الروسيه تنتهي استراتيجيه
وبتحاول ان هي تقوم بتعزيز قدرتها
العسكريه من خلال تغيير التكتيكات
القتاليه خلال الاسابيع الماضيه من خلال
استخدام الصواريخ بعيده المدى القصف
الصاروخي استخدام الطائرات المسيره بدون
تيار استخدام ايضا تعزيز قدرته في اقليم
دونتس زياده قواتها العسكريه الى مليون
ونصف مليون جندي في على اراضي اوكرانيا
لتحقيق هدف الهدف هو ان تستمر في السيطره
على اقليم همم على اقاليم الشرقي دنيا اسك
ولو جانسي وبالتالي بنجد ان خلال الفترات
السابقه لابد ان يلجا الطرفين الى الحل
الوسط وهو لللجوء الى المفاوضات وخاصه ان
روسيا والقوات الروسيه بتظهر كثير من
الحزم في العمليات وبتحقق اهدافها وهي
بتقوم بتدمير اهداف القيمه المضاده
الممثله في محطات الطاقه و40% من اوكرانيا
الان م- بدون طاقه وضع بيعتبر سلاح كبير
جدا للاستخدام لخفض الروح المعنويه لدى
الشعب الاخراني انا باعتقد ان القوات
الروسيه تحقق نجاحات كبيره الرئيس همم
الرئيس الروسي بوتين غير العقيده العسكريه
البحريه الى عقيده عسكريه بحريه جديده في
الثالث من يوليو من العام الماضي وخاصه ان
يعني شفنا ان خلال الاسابيع الماضيه هو
التحاق الفرقاطه غرش كوف الى الخدمه
القتاليه ده كل ذلك بيقول ان العقيده
العسكريه البحريه بتهتم بها روسيا او ما
يطلق عليها الكيلو ركراكيا اي الاعتماد
على القوه البحريه وليس التلاس لا شكرا يا
الاعتماد على القوه البريه فالان بيتم
الاعتماد على القوه البريه لان مساحه همم
روسيا كما نعلم هي اكبر مساحه في العالم
17 مليون كم مربع الان بتلجا الى ايضا الى
القوه البحريه التي في اللغه اليونانيه
القديمه يطلق عليها التراثيه طيب حسن
عبيدي لحتى انت في هذا التقرير اننا لم
نسمع الحديث عن مساله وقف الحرب او السلام
ماذا طبعا ما انتبهت اليه هناك اسرار من
جانب اوكراني
بضروره تحرير كافه الارض الاوكرانيه وهناك
ايضا تعنت من الجانب الروسي حفاظا على
الدباس
صحيح هناك يعني نرى لاول مره اعتقد بدايه
الحرب ان روسيا تحاول تغلي بكل ثقلها في
هذه المنطقه لانها منطقه حساسه امن في
النهايه منطقه الدباس واذا استطاعت ان
تفاوض واذا قبل المجتمع الدولي تفاوض فهي
من المؤكده تحاول ان تفاوض وتحافظ على هذه
المنطقه الشرقيه في نفس الوقت يعني راينا
انه منذ سنه 1941 يعني هناك تعيين قائد
جديد لعمليه في اوكرانيا في نفس الوقت هذا
الرجل يعني يعني هو رقم ثلاثه في
التنظيم بعد الوزير الدفاع داخل روسيا
ويحتفل كمال هذه داخل روسيا مما يعني فعلا
بان هناك نوع او تخطيط جديد من قبل
الروسيه لكن لا يمكن الحكم على هذه
العمليه والقول بان في النهايه ان روسيا
هي في مرحله تقدم بالعكس يعني بعد سنه راى
قتل بانه هناك اخفاقات كبيره
على اداره العمليه العسكريه اداره
النقطه في يعني جانب تاثرت الى جانب
الاوكراني اوكرانيا الان يعني تصلها اسلحه
هناك يعني لاول مره بعض الدول التي كانت
متردده في ارسال اسلحه نوعيه وافقت او
وسيكون هناك برنامج التدريب عسكريين على
استخدام اسلحه مضاده للصواريخ فتره
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه فهناك تسارع
فعل نعمه عسكريه وكان بين الروس
المتحده خاصه والحلف الاطلسي بعد التوقيع
على اتفاقيه او الشراكه همم يومين وهكذا
شراكه مهمه جدا بين الاتحاد
التقدم عسكري كبير خاصه في مجال الدفاعي
والانح حتى المجله الهجومي
همم الذخائر العسكري التي تصل الى الكره
الارضيه حتى من بولونيا يعني من دوله ال-
قريبه همم
ان تشكل تغيير القوى هناك تملم عدم مريضه
بهذا الوضع المجمد عسكريا
طيب تريدين التفاعل مع ما قاله وضيف من
القاهره لا
طبعا تفضلي تفضلي
همم سيد عبيدي بنسبه الى همم الاسلحه
الموجوده همم لنذهب شرقا الى حيث كنا همم
من الواضح جدا ان الجانب الاوكراني على
الاقل في جبهه محمود وهذا ما بدا واضحا في
تقريرنا يعني انا غطيت كما تعلم توفيق
غطيت همم في سوريا معارك كانت قاسيه حتى
دخلت فيها قوه التحالف مثل الرقه وغيرها
في مناطق مثل ما لي لكن ما سمعته من اصوات
حرب في بخموت لم اسمعه في اي تغطيه لي سبق
حتى في اوكرانيا علما انني كنت مثلا في
دبل في العام 2014
بهزيمه كبيره
السلاح المدفعي في تلك المنطقه لا يتوقف
وعندما نقول لا يتوقف بالفعل يتوقع
24 ساعه في الساعه نفسها لا يتوقف لها بل
في الدقيقه يعني من الامور
تبدو غريبه ولكن حقيقه نحن الصحفيين عاده
عندما نسمع صوتا ما نتوقف نحاول ان نقوم
بعملنا في بخموت لم يكن هناك مجال لكل هذا
كنا نستطيع ان نعد احيانا 30 ضربه قريبه
وبعيده بعضها يخرج بعضها يدخل في الدقيقه
الواحده لك ان تتخيل هذا ومع هذا كانت
هناك وهنا اعود الى ما قاله سيد عبيدي
كانت هناك شكوى من الجانب الاوكراني عن
النقص في الذخيره احيانا كانت هناك جبهات
مضطره الى عدم استعمال تحديدا المدفعيه
نعلم ان هناك لن ندخل في تعداد همم ادوات
الحربيه انواع المدفعيه وغيرها تتحدث عن
همم هاون من اكثر من عيار نتحدث عن دبابات
عن مدفعيه الجانب الاوكرانيا يقول نحن
حاجه الى تسليح السؤال الذي يطرح هو حتى
اللحظه الجانب الروسي كان يعتمد على اسلحه
لا شك انها خدمه او اتيه من خلال الحقبه
السوفياتيه الكل يسال هذا سؤال حتى انا لا
جواب ملموسه لديه
سنحاول الاسلحه الحديثه التي تملكها روس
الجيل الجديد هل تحتفظ بها كي لا تحرق
اوراقها خشيه تدخلي حرب اكبر محل في شمال
الاطلسي ام لا هناك خلل كبير في جهاز
العمل الحربي الروسي يجب التوقف عندها
ربما هذا السؤال وجهه يعني لماذا استخدام
اسلحه قديمه تعيد تعود الى العهد السوفيتي
والاحتفاظ بالاسلحه الحديثه التي صنعتها
روسيا
والله الاستاذ عم عيسى انا يعني عاوز ارد
بس على مايسه وبقول فعلا ان الاسلحه
الروسيه بتحقق تدمير كامل في كل البناء
التحتيه وفي اهداف القوه المضاده الممثله
في القواعد الجويه ومراكز الدفاع الجوي
ومواقع الدفاع الجوي وحققت تدمير كبير في
في اوكرانيا وبالتالي بنجد ان يعني روسيا
لديها اسلحه متقدمه يكفي انه يوجد الصاروخ
في سركم هذا الصاروخ اللي هو فرض صوتي
يعني سرعته درجه استخدامها في المقابل اذا
قلبنا الصيف في هذا المنطقه ايضا اوكراني
استطاعت ان تستهدف عمق الاراضي الروسيه في
خلق امريكا
وهنا الاسئله
الحرب الان يعني قاربت على 11 شهر
وبالتالي ان احنا بنجد انه ان الجانب
الاوكراني لم يحقق اي شيء سوى سوى حاجه
بسيطه جدا هي تدمير اوكرانيا بالكامل الان
ويكفي ان يعني اهداف البنيه التحتيه
المدمره ده كله للضغط على الشعب الاوكراني
حتى يفور ضديته اعتقد ان الزلينيسكي لم
ينجح في شيء سوى ان هو يعني دمر مقدرات
اوكرانيا يكفي ان هناك 200 جندي يوميا
ويقتلوا و50 الف مدني وثمانيه مليون في
اكثر من يعني كثير من الدول يكفي بولندا
فيها يعني مليون ونصف فقط وبولندا مهم جدا
تعتبر هي الرئه الاساسيه
لاوكرانيا لان كل الاسلحه الغربيه هي
بتاتي عن طريق بولندا
ان الغرب والولايات المتحده الامريكيه بكل
هذا الدعم اللي هو صرف حتى الان وبكل هذا
الانفاق العسكري الكبير وبكل منظومات
التسليح اللي انا باعتقد انها حتى الان
منظومات تسليح يعني دفاعيه وليست هجوميه
لم تحدث ان تم استهداف الاراضي الروسيه
غير مره واحده اورمر او مرتين في خلال ال
11 شهر وتخشى لولاك المتحده الامريكيه من
اعطاء اوكرانيا اسلحه تصل الى العمق
الروسي لان ذلك اعتقد ان روسيا لا تحارب
همم اوكرانيا فقط ولكنها تحارب حلف
الناتولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ولا يمكن الا ان اتوقع عندما لمسته على
الارض انت تقول ان ذيلانسكي لم يحقق شيئا
دمر بلده من خلال مشاهداتنا على الارض
عمليا شعبيه هل رئيس الاوكراني عاليه هيا
بالطبع ضربات قلبنا التحتيه ومحطات
الكهرباء والطاقه هذا امر محبط للغايه
للشعب الاوكراني لكنه بالنسبه على الاقل
للذين تحدثت اليهم فقط لاكمل هذه الفكره
من المناصرين همم
لزلينسكي هذه النقطه تؤخذ
معزلنسكي وليس ضده ضد الجانب الروسي ضد
بوتين في المقلب الاخر تتحدث عن تنمل ايضا
يعني وهذا اعود دائما الى التقرير كي
بالفكره يعني ذهبنا كانت صعوبه بالغه مثلا
ان نجد والد انجلينا الذي رايته
تقول ان كل هذا اصلا كان خطا فادحا
وعمليا بين متزوجين كم من ينتظر
اصلا
انا لا اخذ الموقف الروسي ضد ان انت بتخزي
الموقف الاخراني احنا في اتجاه اعتقد نحن
نتحدث
تمام يا فندم عندما يكون هناك 20 في المئه
من اوكرانيا محتله وتم السيطره في الشرق
وفي الجنوب كيف تقول ذلك عندما يكون هناك
ثمانيه مليون مواطن لاجئين في دول اخرى
كيف ان يكون ذلك يعني في صالح همم الشعب
الاوكراني وفي صالح زيسكي ازاي ان يكون
هناك يعني محطات القوه تحتاج
شبكه الكهرباء مليار ونصف الملياردولار
حتى يتم رجوعها مره ثانيه كيف اعاده
البناء مره ثانيه ويحتاج 900 مليار دولار
من قام بذلك اليس الان لو حدث تفاوض الان
بين الجانب الروسي والجانب الاوكراني
ولجاوا الى طاوله المفاوضات ماذا سيحدث
اخيرا سيكون هناك يعني استفتاء على
الاقاليم الاربعه التي روسيا ضمتها اليها
نتيجه الاستفتاء لكن التدمير موجود احنا
نعلم ان كل الاسلحه الغربيه التي تدعم بها
الغرب والولايات المتحده الامريكيه همم
لاوكرانيا هي ديون على اوكرانيا سيتم
تسديد كل تلك الانفاق اللي موجود لما 200
جندب اوكراني بيتم قتلهم يوميه من اختار
شهر كيف يكون ذلك في صالح الشعب الاوكراني
انا يعني هناك وعمليه التصعيد توفيق لو
سمحت هناك قلب للصوره يعني انا اعتقد الذي
اولا تدمير البنيه التحتيه ليس انتصار ليس
انتصار للرئيس بوتين بالعكس يعني تقريبا
مؤشرات الايجابيه هناك تخبط كبيره للقياده
الروسيه زي ذلك التغيير المستمر في
القيادات العسكريه القياده الروسيه منذ
البدايه قالت بانها ستقوم بعمليه عسكريه
وليست حرب وانها ستحسم في ظل بعض اسابيع
الان اشرفنا على سنه ولم تحقق في النهايه
القياده الروسيه بالعكس الرئيس بودي قال
انه يريد التفاوض لكن لكن بشروته ما قام
بهذا الرئيس
كيف يمكن ان نتفاوض عندما تكون هناك اكثر
من 120,000 30,000 جندي عسكري روسيا
يقومون بناورات على الحدود
يجب ان ننتبه نقطه مه جدا وهي قضيه محاوله
خلق خريطه جديده تغيير حدود اوكرانيا تحت
اي مسماه- مرفوض مرفوض اوكرانيات ومرفوض
حتى بالنسبه للقانون الدولي اما ما قام
بها يا دكتور حسني لا لا نعم
فكره فقط قضيه اساسيه الان يعني حتى لا
اعود الى ق
ضيه اوكرانيا سترى يعني في النهايه
المجتمع الغربي قادر جدا امتصاص ديون
اوكرانيا واثبت فعلا قوه كبيره على دعم
الاقتصادي سننتقل الى مرحله مقبله في
الاسابيع المقبله اكيد حول قضيه تغيير
السلاح النوعي لان بالنسبه للغرب حتى
بالنسبه لو كان تصوير ما يقع اليوم في
سيدار مثلا في هذه المنطقه التي كانت فيها
زميله يلعبون سته سيكون احد المباريات
الاساسيه بالنسبه للمشته بالنسبه للمجتمع
المدني بالنسبه للاحزاب السياسيه التي ما
زالت تتردد في في مضاعفه المجهود الحربي
لان بالنسبه للغرب سقوط اوكرانيا معناها
سقوط الغرب معناها سقوط الديمقراطيه هذا
التفسير ولذلك لا اعتقد ان لروسيا سيد عبد
المنصره في هذا نعمتك كثيرا في مساله
التمويل مساله اعاده الاعمار ولا ننسى انه
في الحديث في الشارع الاوكراني هناك جهه
تقول نحن جهه محتله ونحن مقاومون وبالتالي
الحسابات لا تحسب بل من لين الممكنه هناك
تعويل ولكن هناك نقطه ايضا توجهها بها لها
علاقه به ما نتحدث الان في منذ سنه وكنت
انا عند من دلعت كل هذه الحرب كنت في
ماريو بول انا ذاك كانت الصدمه هائله كانت
القضمه الروسيه للاراضي الاوكرانيه كبيره
مع انني من الذين يصرون على ان الحرب بدات
منذ عام 2014 لم تبدا العام الماضي عاليا
الان اليوم نحن نتحدث عن ماذا نتحدث عن
دوم بس عن منطقه عندما اتحدث عن المعارك
عن سوليدار وعن بخموت بمعنى كما لو ان
هناك شئنا ام ابينا
الانتصار هذا
الاصرار تحديدا على مخموت وعلى سوليدار
واعتقد انكما ستوافقان اننا بدنا نتحدث عن
منطقه صغيره حتى دخلت فيها مجموعه فاجنر
بكامل في قلها ولا يمكن ان انسى هذه
العباره التي اطلقها بريكوجين همم من همم
راس الهرم في مجموعه
ماذا قال عن بخمود قال ستكون وهنا اقتبس
مفرمه اللحم اللحم البشري
كل هذا الثقه المنذ اشهر موضوع للسيطره
على مدينه محمود التي ان اردنا بعيدا عن
كل التحويل
بمعنى ستكون رمزيه بالطبع كل مدينه هي
استراتيجيه في الحرب لكن اذا قسناها بما
بالانسحاب من خرسان اذا قسناها بالانسحاب
شمالا الان روسيا با تريد اي انتصار على
الارض لانها لم تحقيقها بكل بساطه منذ
اشهر تفضل
والله عايز اقول فعلا ان دخول الحرب يعني
همم ده عاده بيكون اسهل من الخروج منه
الخروج من الحرب
مش معروف يعني بنعرف توقيت البدايه ولا
نعرف توقيت النهايه وباعتقي وجهه نظري ان
الدعم الغربي وهذه الاسلحه اللي هي وصلت
الى 100 مليار دولار
الى اوكرانيا هي اللي بتطيل امد الصراع
احنا بنقول يعني في المفكر الامريكي نعوم
توشيماسك بيقول ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تطيل تريد ان تطيل ابد الصراع
حتى اخر جند اوكراني الحرب ليس بين روسيا
واوكرانيا الحرب بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبين روسيا على اساس تغيير
النظام العالمي ليكون متعدد الاقطاب بدلا
من القطب الواحد وبالتالي العقل والمنط
بيقول انه يجب اللجوء الى طاوله المفاوضات
كل يوم في خسائر احنا شايفين سليدار
وبخمود ايه الخسائر اللي بيتم فيها وازاي
ان القوات فضنا بتقول ان هي سيطرت على
مخمود هذه المدينه الاستراتيجيه هذه اقدم
مركز تجاري وثقافي
اسمحي لي بس
اسمحيلي يا استاذه تفضلي في رؤيه الامور
هناك تقارير بتقول ان قوات فاطمه والقوات
المحموله جوا سيطرت على المدخل الشمالي
والمدخل الجنوبي وهناك تمشيط للمنطقه دي
تقارير بتذكر
سيطره على بخموط هناك حتى في التقرير
تحدثنا عن وجود شرقا
صحيحا
هناك قتال هذا القتال بينتج عنه خسائر
تستمر الخسائر تبني عندما يلجا الطرفان
الى طاوله المفاوضات ايه اللي هيتم
هيكون هناك شروط ما بين او هناك مطالب
للطرفين اعتقد ان روسيا الطلب الاول ان
اوكرانيا لا تنضم الى حلف النيه
طب ما كان من الاول خالص لا يتم يعني يكون
هناك اجراءات بعدم الانضمام الى حلف
الناتو اللي هو يعني
المفكر الروسي الدوجن بيقول ان المجال
الحيوي الروسي هي اوكرانيا وبالتالي ما
نجيبش اسلحه استراتيجيه وتكون على حدود
روسيا وبالتالي عندما يتم التفاوض الان
والحل السلمي هنقول كل الكلام والتدمير
اللي حصل ده كان ممكن الا يحدث في حاله
الاستجابه الى المطالب الروسيه التي كل
شهر والولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا تريد
ذلك لا تريد ذلك لا تريد انهاء يعني لا
يعني ليست لديك اراده ولا الرغبه ان ترفض
لاي شعب ان ينضم الى تنظيم عسكري معين او
الى اي تنظيم او اي دمشق اقتصادي هناك
رغبه للاوكرانيين النقطه الفلان الحيوي
انا اعتقد المجال
تفاوض
بالنسبه للتفاوض بدون شروط التفاوض الناجح
بدون
على الخصم على اوكرانيا بان تعود ان تعتبر
اعتراف بالمناطق المنظمه الاربعه ثم كذلك
تحييين الحدود الى غير ذلك فانت في
النهايه غلقتها باب التفاوض ولذلك منذ
البدايه كانت هناك كلب مفتوحه للتفاوض
للاسف الان وصلنا الى مرحله متقدمه وانا
شخصيا لا اعتقد بان الاطراف الان هي يعني
مستعده او ان التفاوض السياسي اصبح ناضجا
لان كل الطرفين لماذا
يا دكتور حسني نعم نعم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تفضل
استطاعت في النهايه ان تجد اللحمه ما بين
اوروبا وبين الحلف الاطلسي كان هناك تحويل
كبير على فرنسا حتى المانيا كانت رافضه
الى اخر دقيقه تسليح اوكرانيا لكن لم تسجل
استجابه ايجابيه من طرف الروسي فاستطاعت
الولايات المتحده في النهايه ان تجلب لها
كل الدول الغربيه حتى تلك المتردده والتي
كانت تقول لا بدل الحل السياسي ولذلك
القياده الروسيه يقول تتحمل جزء كبير من
هذه المسؤوليه ضرب البنيه التحتيه المجازر
التي ارتكبت كذلك المقابر الجماعيه التي
اكتشفت هناك قضايا مصر القانون الدولي
الانساني حقوق الانسان لا يعتقد ان
المجتمع الدولي يمكن ان يتغافل عليها
فنعتقد التفاوض نعم ممكن هو الخيار الانسب
لكن بدون اي شروط محاوله اعاده رسم خريطه
السعوديه
تفضل كنت شاهده على العصر عندما كنت على
اتصال مباشر بالجنود هل ما نسمعه في كل
النقاشات حول احتمال هذا مطروح ام ان نحن
في واد
والواقع على الارض بواخر
حياديه بين الطرفين ان اقول ان ما نقوله
في مكان والجنود الذين يعيشون ليل نهار
احلى عوده تم تخطي مراحل كثيره بالنسبه
الى الاوكرانيين هناك خوف على الهويه خوف
على العائله هناك خسائر هائله الان
الكل يعتبر هذه المعركه معركه وجود كل طرف
له روايته لكن بالنسبه الى الجانب
الاوكراني كل ما يقال الان حتى هناك سيكون
صعوبه اذا في هذه اللحظه الان يقول الجانب
الثاني نريد ان نتفاوض سوف يكون السؤال
على اي اساس الان الثمن لاي مفاوضات نحن
نعلم ان كل الحروب بشكل عام انتهت اما
بيغلب او مغلوب عسكريين او بالجلوس وتوقيع
على اتفاقيات هذا سياتي لكن باي ثمن ومتى
حتى لحظه الطرفان يظن انهما سينتصران وكل
طرف يرفض التنازل الجانب الروسي يقول
مستمر في حربه الجانب الاوكراني يقول انه
يدافع عنك كيان ولا باكثر من هذا يشكر
الجانب الروسي على اعتبار انه هكذا يدير
ظهره لمكان الشقيق الروسي بلا اي ندم نظرا
للخسائر الكبيره في صفوف الاوكرانيين
في نهايه البرنامج
لا ابدا انا عايز اقول فعلا ان عندما يتم
تقليل الدعم ده هيقلل الصراع اللجوء الدول
الغربيه نفسها هي متضرره هناك 500 مليار
دولار خسائر للغرب نتيجه ارتفاع اسعار
الطاقه والصلع الغذائيه هي متضرره وهناك
مظاهرات في الدول الغربيه وهناك زلينيسك
عندما زار الولايات المتحده الامريكيه قبل
علشان كان في الكونجرس الامريكي كان
الديمقراطين هم المسيطرين علشان يبقى في
47 مليار دولار دعم عسكري خلال عام 20 23
قبل ان يقوم الجمهوريون يعني برئاسه
الكونجرس وبالتالي بيعتقد ان الغرب
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكانت زياره
الرئيس اليونيسك الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هي بدايه بادره لللجوء السياسي
والحل السياسي والدبلوماسي لان الكل هيكون
كسبان من هذا الحل السياسي لكن
تصعيد هناك يعني الرسائل التصعيديه فين في
خلال الفترات القادمه ليس في صالح الشعب
الاوكراني الخسائر كلها في اوكرانيا ليست
في الغرب ولا في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه احنا نعلم ان العالم
في نهايه البرنامج
[ضحك]
اقتصاديه واهزات اجتماعيه لكن دعمه
لاوكرانيا اعتقد
اشكرك في الختام محمد شهاوي ومستشار في
كره القدم المصريه الشكر لحسنا فيديو
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه جنوب
الشكر للزميله ليس عواد برافو على هذا
التقرير لك جيمس
شكرا لفريق البرنامج امسيه مريحه للجميع
[موسيقى]